papa j'ai peur connaît bien hélicoptère
qui nous attend sur le toit ne quitte
pas maman et moi des yeux d'accord on
est vraiment sûr qu'ils vont venir qui
vont venir
voilà l objectif on descend
à
en fait
monsieur le secrétaire adjoint monsieur
le secrétaire adjoint dit que vous étiez
son meilleur enquêteur aux nations unies
je vous veux sur le cas avec l'équipe
aider le professeur fastback à trouver
ce dont il a besoin
tu m'avais venir je voulais que les
circonstances par le d'elle-même
je peux rien pour vous je laisserai pas
ma famille
regardez autour de vous le soleil
chacune de ces personnes est ici parce
qu'elle sert un but il n'y a pas de
place pour du personnel non essentiel
vous voulez aider votre famille
réfléchissons aux moyens de mettre un
terme à tout ça à vous de choisir le
soleil